my god they've finally made a remake of
Clue I had no idea its clue that no one
gives a [ __ ] edition the loft don don ah
so the loft is a murder mystery who does
this group of guys you don't give a [ __ ]
about they'll share a loft where they
take chicks and they bang them to cheat
on their wives and this loft does you
know no credit cards no hotel it's
cleaner that way then one day one of
them comes they're like oh my god
there's a dead chick in the bed we're
the only ones with the keys ooh it must
have been one of us but who didn't you
get a sequence of backstories that are
filling in the gaps for you and
unraveling the movie seriously my god
all right I love a good murder mysteries
like oh [ __ ] who did it I'm trying to
figure it out I'm trying to be smarter
than the movie but you make one fatal
mistake in this movie you assume the
movies smart to begin with so you're
thinking up here and really the movies
kind of found
mmm it's here very few things in this
movie makes sense not to mention the
fact that in order to engage you you
have to give a [ __ ] about any of the
main characters Karl Urban is the one
you care about the most sure other than
that you got James Marsden Captain Cold
I know he's the dude from Prison Break
but I'm gonna call him Captain Cold
because that's who he is in flash you
got Johnny Koch rage in the cop from
bunker when special guest appearance
Skeletor and Karl Urban they're flirting
and they're talking I was like who won
where did this dialogue come from who
writes this [ __ ] will don't actually
talk like this I've known a lot of
people in my life so I'm live here some
live there some live in LA I know people
in LA they don't even talk like this and
they're aliens that wasn't a Mexico or
an immigration joke I'm saying they're
actually from outer space and then this
movie I want to give it credit because
at a point it's like maybe it'll get
interesting it looks like it my kid nope
we're back where you going we got you
can't go that low and then the
revelation happens in another one in
another it just gets convoluted by the
end then I was the only one in the movie
theater so when I say I said this don't
worry it was just me cuz the rest of the
world smarter than me I guess I went oh
my god movie end so shortly after that
it finally ended but [ __ ] this movie's
easily 20 minutes too long how can I be
bored a murder mystery in which
everybody in this small group of friends
they're all the suspects that should be
awesome but I was like a 6th grader
watched an episode or two of Mad Men
like I can write it better my god what a
waste of time little wasted space
seriously it's a shitty ass version of
clewd which case you win the game by
saying but I got it I got I know who
killed the audience it was the loft in
the movie theater with boredom oh my god
you always how did you know that oh
that's kind of easy because I was there
The Loft is a mess wrapped in a disaster
splattered with [ __ ] give in January
the slow clap cuz it just kept trying it
had to bore the [ __ ] out of us at least
one more time so the loft have you seen
it what did you think about you're not
gonna see this there's like 200 people
on the planet that know about this movie
50 of them were involved in the making
of this movie the rest of the people
they saw it in a youtube ad somewhere
I'm never gonna ask you alright so
what's your favorite murder mystery of
all time I think I've asked you that
before well just chalk it up to new
people on the channel whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you